en province c'est peut-être o'meara et à
toulouse que les affrontements ont été
les plus importants en dix jours plus de
225 voitures ont été brûlées et un jeune
incendiaire a eu la main arrachée par
une grenade lacrymogène
là aussi la nuit dernière c'était
l'accalmie avec un mélange de
résignation et d'espoir face aux
problèmes de fond de ces quartiers
isabel dos lyon david bres les enfants
ont repris leurs parties de foot sur le
béton au pied des barres d'immeubles
on ne voit plus ces groupes de jeunes
aux comportements imprévisibles
le grand conseil sur light qui
travaillent jean moorlag les jeunes
arrêtés au congrès et au souk aux
arrêtés
vous cherchez des travaux à l'école même
si cinq voitures ont encore brûlés la
nuit dernière à toulouse les sites et
retrouvent leur calme
au grand soulagement des habitants mais
on est dans le bâtiment où on est
bombardé de chaque côté c est vivable
quoi et là ça s'est calmé et donc c'est
beaucoup mieux oui on n'a plus peur de
sortir
on est apaisé par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé dernièrement bon on souhaite que
ça se calme davantage signe encourageant
le métro qui ne desservait plus les
quartiers sensibles après 20h a repris
un service normal mais dans les
associations l'on aide les jeunes à
remplir des cv on leur conseille
toujours de changer de numéro de code
postal c'est calme et rennes en charge
et mais bon j'espère que la roue moindre
on a écouté
s'ils veulent pas que ça pète une
deuxième fois à les problèmes de fond
c'est pas un seul logement comme je
disais il travaille à toulouse on
n'offre pas de logement à n'importe qui
n'importe où c'est ça promet les jeunes
parlent de leur quartier comme d'une
cocotte-minute dont la pression ne
baissera que quand ils se sentiront
vraiment intégré dans la ville